there's a story in the news about a
possible threat to the u.s. from our
northern border did you know that it's
true this is a true story u.s. wildlife
officials are saying Montana may soon be
invaded by feral hogs from Canada yes
feral hogs have you heard of feral hogs
and Kenneth it's a big yeah yeah it's a
big problem
yeah thanks for backing me up on this
whole thing I sort of got ahead we had
no idea well me we decided to talk about
this today that you'd be in the front
row but now we got expert testimony yeah
and your feral - feral hogs are coming
down from Canada the hogs are already
causing a ton of damage on the us-canada
border now here's the interesting thing
our show happens to have a writer that's
from Canada and he's asked to come out
and say a few words about this story so
please welcome our shows only Canadian
writer Levi mcdougal
you feel hey handy pie Levi hey beau
uncle Bruce
Oh
[Applause]
in America hey okay well for America hi
with me a list of demands that your
country must fulfill if you want Canada
to call off the feral hogs and you must
meet all of these demands or the Hogs
will come ok demand number one the super
bowl must now be played on ice as God
meant for it to be demand number two
stop visiting Canada just for cheap
prescription drugs and affordable
insulin we also have the world's tallest
nickel and a bunch of shirts Wayne
Gretzky's to where no one wants to see
any of them number three number three
Americans must stop referring to the US
as the greatest country on Earth instead
you must now say hey we had some good
years hey and finally demand number four
Guantanamo Bay must now be used to
imprison anyone who says aboot when
they're pretending to speak like a
Canadian and look here's the thing
we don't say aboot we say about but you
say about when you guys try to say about
you say a boot because you can't
pronounce the subtle nuances of our
beautiful dialect anyway enjoy Gitmo
it's about time
so America those are Canada's demands if
you want us to call off the hog invasion
Coenen you got all that all right well
yeah but Levi there's no way no way the
United States is gonna do all that stuff
just no way really yeah yeah really
they're not gonna do it not gonna do it
well then I have no choice
release the hood
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I say bring them on they're adorable we
got a great show from the American Pie
movies in the new movie bloodlines Sean
William Scott is on
[Applause]
me and China Friedman's here
[Applause]